نستكمله مشوارنا في العلا محافظه العلا
ذات الطبيعه الساحره وتماشيا مع مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء تحتضن اول بنك للبذور
يضم 600,000 نوع منها البنك سيسهم في
الحفاظ على النباتات المحليه المعرضه
للانقراض مثل عرعر وكذلك في زياده الغطاء
النباتي والذي بدوره يساعد في اعاده
التوازن الطبيعي في محافظه العلا
والسعوديه بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
على كل من العلم
مراسله صباح العربيه نادين اهلا بك من
جديد من الاولى هذه المره بتقول لك مكانك
فاضي بس منوره العلماء مره جديده حدثيني
عن بذور الحياه في العلا نتيجه
تسلمي يا سهام وان شاء الله يعني انتم
معانا هون موجودين في قلبنا في هذا المجلس
المجلس في العلا من بين مزارع العلا وبين
جبالها الخلابه طبعا سيكون معانا ضيفنا
هنا في الاستديو الخارجي من هذا المجلس
لصباح العربيه المهندس سامي المالكي
المدير العام المكلف سنه ومشاكل النباتات
لبنك البذور اهلا بكم
عندما نسمع عن اسم البذور يعني اسم لافث
بنك البدور اسئله كثيره تصار في اذهاننا
ماذا يعني بنك البذور اولا الحقيقه برنامج
جمع البذور المحليه والمحافظه عليها اهم
برامج التنميه الغطاء النبات اللي بدات
الهيئه الملكيه العمل عليها من عام 2019
ويستهدف الى جميع بذور النباتات المحليه
والمحافظه عليها وتخزينها وكذلك اجراء
التجارب واختبارات الانبات
ليه استخدامنا لاحقا في الانتاج واعاده
زراعتها في المواقع المستهلكه طيب ما هي
اليه العمل يعني كيف
تستدامه النباتات
وبالتالي البذور الحقيقه احنا نستهدف 4
نوع نباتي في محافظه العلا
وتبدا العمليه بجمع هذه النباتات اللي
عددها 4 نباتي ثم انتاجها في مشاكل متخصصه
فيبدا بفريق ميداني في المحميات الطبيعيه
والمواقع الطبيعيه المستهدفه ثم انتاجها
في المشاكل بعد مرور هذه البذور في في
البنك او في محطات المعالجه ها طيب اليوم
نحن نتحدث في المملكه العربيه السعوديه عن
مستقبل اكثر خضره وبالتالي نمط حياه افضل
وطبعا نذكر
بالسعو بمبادره السعوديه الخضراء فبالتالي
اصبح العالم اجمع بحاجه للتحرك الى مستقبل
اكثر خضره اليوم اذا ما تحدثنا بشكل خاص
عن العلا حملات التشجير البرامج التي
يشارك بها حاليا
لديها برامج طموح جدا في الاستدامه
الاراضي وكذلك المشاركه هذه العلاقه في
مشاريع غرس الاشجار ومشاريع التشجير بدانا
في ثلاث حملات حتى الان تسجيل همم يغسل
النباتات المحليه في محافظه العلا شارك
معنا اكثر من اربعه الاف متطور حتى الان
عندنا طموح كبير لزراعه 1080
وبالتالي عدد المتطوعين عدد المشاركين ان
شاء الله سيطره يا رب
استني اذا ما تحدثنا عن نوعيه النباتات
مثلا لو تحدثنا اكثر بالتفصيل يعني هلا ان
نتخيل طبيعه المشاكل طبيعه البذور التي
يتم تطويرها لتحقيق الاستدامه في الغطاء
النباتي نتكلم على اكثر
فنتكلم عن اشجار مثل الطلح وانواعها
والسدر اتكلم على شجيرات مثل الارض والغضا
ونتكلم على على نباتات موسميه مثل الخزام
همم تكلم على على بناء مجتمع نباتي في
العلا وليس فقط جرائد الشهر بل اعاده
المجتمع النباتي كامل الى الى منطقه العلا
كما نتوقع انه كان سابقا وكما يتوقع انه
يكون مناسب همم نظام الحيوي
طيب احنا نشكرك جزيل الشكر المهندس سامي
المالكي المدير العام المكلف لالبست له
ومشاهده النباتات شكرا جزيلا